francia tiene la capacidad de acoger a
100.000 refugiados ucranianos de los
cuales ya ha acogido a cerca de 13.000 y
se está preparando para recibir más las
autoridades trabajan para alojar a los
migrantes en gimnasios y otros lugares
públicos y celebran la ola de
solidaridad de los particulares que
proponen acoger a familias en su casa
aquí en francia como en otros países hay
personas que tienen un impulso de
generosidad ciudadanos que se dicen a sí
mismos voy a ir a la estación o al
aeropuerto para encontrarme con una
familia ucraniana y ofrecerle venir a mi
casa guillaume language vivien list en
el norte de francia acoge en su casa a
catherine a su madre y su hermano somos
padres pensamos que algún día podríamos
estar en la misma situación y por eso
decidimos ofrecernos a acoger a una
familia ucraniana kateryna y a su
familia les tomo siete días llegar a
francia
llegaron con solo tres mochilas ya que
en la estación de ucrania tuvieron que
abandonar otras cosas para que más gente
pudiera subir al tren
agradezco a todas las personas que se
preocupan por por este momento tan
difícil para nosotros aquí me siento
bien estoy a salvo pero por otro lado
tengo mucho miedo por ucrania y por la
gente que se quedó allá mi familia
de
europa estableció un estatuto particular
para los refugiados ucranianos disfrutan
de una protección temporal que les
permite quedarse un año en cualquier
país del bloque trabajar y acceder al
sistema de salud permiso que se puede
prorrogar dos veces por seis meses